so recently I had a question I want to
clarify relating to vitamin D and
calcium okay because one of the side
effects of too much vitamin D it's
called hypervitaminosis D which is
vitamin D toxicity would be high levels
of calcium in the blood and of course
that could potentially lead to
calcification of your arteries okay so I
wanted to differentiate that from what
really happens and I'm gonna put a link
down below of some really great research
in this area vitamin D inversely
correlates to coronary artery
calcification which means when you
increase your vitamin D you actually
decrease the calcification in the
coronary artery okay that you would
think it would just be the opposite but
that's not the way it works vitamin D is
a fat-soluble vitamin and it's even
carried by lipoproteins like HDL and LDL
are lipoproteins that transports certain
fats cholesterol triglycerides and fat
soluble vitamins like vitamin A vitamin
E and even vitamin D since fat and
essential fatty acids and fats I bottom
ins don't mix well with water they need
to be transported with these proteins
now you would assume that because
vitamin D has to do with calcium
absorption and increase in calcium in
the blood that that would automatically
just deposit and calcify your arteries
but calcium is very very tightly
controlled by a lot of different factors
one is vitamin k2 vitamin k2 works with
vitamin D in that it actually helps
remove excess calcium that vitamin D
created so it takes it out of the
arteries takes it out of the joints and
pushes it into the bone so let's just
take for example an artery that's filled
with calcium we have to understand in an
earlier beginning okay and the beginning
started with some type of oxidation to
the wall of the artery then you had
inflammation and that signaled the
body's healing capacity to lay down
cholesterol in calcium well guess what
vitamin D is probably there to heal this
lesion not necessarily to lay down and
deposit calcium but
there is a part of the healing process
because it's an anti-inflammatory
vitamin in fact taking vitamin D
actually reduces stiffness in the
arteries so it can really really help
someone the point I'm trying to make is
vitamin D is not the problem you you
need to look at the whole picture and I
always recommend if you're taking
vitamin D also take vitamin k2 at the
same time and you're not going to have
any problems with excess calcium even if
you have a large amounts of vitamin D if
you have vitamin K cube alright I'll see
you later
so to prevent me from running out of
content I have a new survey I want to
find out what you are interested in so
please fill it out the links down below